En este video hablaremos sobre el volumen de una
pirámide, y muchos de ustedes ya pueden estar
familiarizados con la fórmula del volumen de una
pirámide, pero el objetivo de este video es ver
algunos argumentos para comprender por qué es esa
la fórmula del volumen de una pirámide. Así que
empecemos por dibujar una pirámide, dibujaremos
una con una base rectangular, pero depende de cómo
veamos la fórmula es que tendremos una versión
más general. Una pirámide se ve más o menos así,
y podemos tener una idea de cuál podría ser
la fórmula para el volumen de una pirámide:
si decimos esta dimensión de aquí es x, esta otra
dimensión o longitud es y, y después tenemos la
altura de esta pirámide que va en línea recta
desde el centro de la base hasta el punto más
alto, o se puede medir esta distancia desde aquí,
esta es la altura de la pirámide, le llamaremos z.
Entonces, podrás decir: "Bien, estoy trabajando
con tres dimensiones, así que tal vez debería de
multiplicar estas tres dimensiones y eso me
dará el volumen pensando en términos de las
unidades". Pero si sólo multiplicáramos x • y •
z, nos daría el volumen del prisma rectangular
completo que contiene a la pirámide, esto nos daría
el volumen de todo esto que es claramente mayor,
tiene un volumen mayor que el de la pirámide
porque podemos ver que la pirámide está adentro,
la pirámide está completamente contenida en él:
aquí tendríamos la punta de la pirámide -tocando
esta cara, justo así-, y entonces puedes tener la
idea de que tal vez el volumen de la pirámide sea
x • y • z por una cierta constante. Y lo que vamos
a hacer en este video es argumentar cuál debe ser
esa constante, suponiendo que el volumen de la
pirámide tiene aproximadamente esta estructura.
Para ayudarnos con esta idea, dibujemos un prisma
rectangular más grande, y vamos a dividirlo en
seis pirámides que compongan completamente
el volumen del prisma rectangular. Primero
pensemos en una pirámide que se va a ver de esta
forma, donde su ancho sea x, su largo sea y,
estas son las medidas de la base, y su altura
será la mitad de la altura del prisma rectangular,
es decir, si el prisma tiene una altura de z, la
pirámide tendrá una altura de z / 2. Ahora bien,
¿cuál es el volumen de la pirámide con base en lo
que vemos aquí? Bueno, el valor del volumen de la
pirámide será igual a una cierta constante k • x
• y, y esta vez no será por zeta, cuidado; tenemos
que multiplicar por la altura de la pirámide, es
decir, por z entre 2, así que vamos a escribirlo:
por z / 2, y podemos escribirlo de esta forma o
también podemos escribirlo de esta otra forma:
xyz / 2. Ahora, podemos construir otra pirámide
que tiene exactamente las mismas dimensiones. Si
ponemos al revés esta pirámide inicial, sólo que
de cabeza, entonces se va a ver más o menos así;
esta pirámide también tendrá como dimensiones un
ancho de x, un largo de y y una altura de z / 2,
así que su volumen también será este. Ahora, ¿cuál
es la suma del volumen de estas dos pirámides
combinadas? Bueno, será esta expresión por 2.
Entonces la suma de los volúmenes combinados
de estas dos pirámides -vamos a dibujarlo para
tenerlo más claro: tenemos dos pirámides que
se ven, así voy a intentar codificarlas por
colores-, tenemos dos pirámides como esta y
entonces su volumen combinado será dos veces esto,
que será simplemente k • x • y •z, kxyz.
Ahora tenemos que trabajar con más pirámides.
Por ejemplo, tenemos esta otra pirámide por aquí,
donde esta cara es su base y se ve justo así,
aquí la tenemos. Ahora, ¿cuál será su volumen?
Su volumen será k por el área de su base, que es
y •z, kyz. Y, ahora, ¿cuál es su altura? Bueno,
su altura es la mitad de x, entonces esta altura
es x / 2, por lo tanto el volumen es k • y •
z •x / 2, o podemos decir todo esto por
x y todo dividido entre 2. Ahora, por acá tenemos
otra pirámide que tiene exactamente las mismas
dimensiones. Esta de acá, si intentamos dibujarla
en la otra cara opuesta a la que acabamos de
ver, básicamente es la misma sólo que la giramos,
tiene exactamente las mismas dimensiones. Así que
una forma de pensarlo es que tenemos dos pirámides
que se ven de esta forma con estas dimensiones.
Y todo esto para un prisma rectangular arbitrario
con el que estamos trabajando. Entonces tenemos
dos de estas pirámides y, por lo tanto, si sumamos
sus dos volúmenes ¿qué obtendremos? Bueno,
será dos veces esta expresión, es decir, será
k • xyz. Interesante. Y por último, pero no por
eso menos importante, tenemos dos pirámides más.
Tenemos esta que tiene esta cara como base, esta
es su base, y si fuera transparente podríamos ser
capaces de ver lo que estamos dibujando. Además,
tenemos otra pirámide en el lado opuesto justo
aquí, en el otro lado, como si giráramos esta
pirámide y, por lo tanto, por el mismo argumento,
si las dibujamos por aquí tenemos dos pirámides de
este tipo -estoy haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo para
dibujarla-, y esto será por 2. Entonces, ¿cuál es
el volumen de cada una de estas pirámides? Cada
una tiene una base de x por z, entonces su volumen
será k • x •z, esta es el área de la base.
Y ahora, ¿cuál es su altura? Bueno, cada una de
ellas tiene una altura de y / 2, entonces esto nos
quedará por y / 2, pero como tengo dos pirámides
vamos a multiplicar esto por 2 y nos quedaremos
con kxyz. Ahora, una de las cosas interesantes
que acabamos de encontrar en todo esto es que a
pesar de que estas pirámides tienen diferentes
dimensiones y se ven distintas, todas tienen el
mismo volumen, lo cual es interesante por sí
mismo. Y ahora, si tuviéramos que sumar todos
los volúmenes de todas estas pirámides, y usamos
esta fórmula para expresarlo, entonces, la suma de
todas debe de ser igual al volumen del prisma
rectangular completo. Y tal vez con esta idea
podemos obtener el valor de k, ya que el volumen
del prisma rectangular completo es xyz, x • y
•z; y eso nos dará la suma de éstos, es decir,
esto será igual a la suma de kxyz + kxyz + kxyz,
o podemos decir que es 3 veces kxyz, lo único
que hicimos fue sumar el volumen de todas estas
pirámides. Entonces, ¿qué valor podemos obtener
para acá? Bueno, podemos dividir ambos lados por 3
veces xyz para despejar acá, entonces dividiremos
entre 3 xyz de ambos lados: en el lado derecho
todo se cancela y nos quedaremos con k, mientras
que en el lado izquierdo nos quedaremos con ⅓,
entonces obtenemos que k = ⅓, k es
igual a un tercio. Y ya lo tenemos,
este es el argumento de por qué el volumen de una
pirámide es ⅓ por las dimensiones de la base por
la altura. Así que puedes verlo de esta forma
o puedes verlo como ⅓ por el área de la base,
x • y es el área de la base, entonces ⅓ por la
base por la altura, que en este caso es z, pero
podemos escribir h para la altura, así es como
también se escribe el volumen de una pirámide,
pero son equivalentes. Y esta es la razón
por la que debemos sentirnos bien con este ⅓.